classement presque envie d'appeler
brigitte pas content pour lui fêter pas
[Musique]
baissé alors l'apple brisé de mâcon
c'est parti alors attendons là c'est
brigitte makrout sahara
c'est pour lui souhaiter bon ramadan
n'ont rien à voir on sait rien à voir
briki macron cboe je laisse équipe à ces
types ah non c'est y pas première dame
de france c'est pas la première à la
deuxième c'est pas la première c'est la
de dépasser la première c'est pas la
deuxième c'est par l'a39 c'est la
première number one tu es ce un message
est oui oui c'est brigitte directement
du souhaite bon anniversaire et là c'est
trop tôt et qu'il ya plus tard parce que
là elle bosse mâles boss et bano aussi
je bosse appelle les on ne sait trop où
aller tranquille que plus tard puis des
services à brigitte c'était cyril
hanouna on était sur le plateau ont
pensé à vous avec un grand v victoire
brigitte voulez vous embrassez vous dire
bon anniversaire
plein de bonnes choses j'ai fait livrer
une table de ping pong à l'elysée
j'espère qu'il va arriver bientôt un
petit père veille de technologie et tout
le plateau
j'aimerais que tout le plateau soit
bonne anniversaire joyeux
[Applaudissements]
résultat
j'ai également ejeie a également envoyé
quelques makrouds avec des bougies
on voit comment la tendance mais le
gouvernement
[Rires]